Нині тут спокійно, проте лише кілька років тому на цих полях точилися інтенсивні бої
між українською армією та проросійськими сепаратистами.
Лінія фронту не раз змінювалась,
і щоразу, відступаючи, військові залишали по собі чимало мін.
Тепер їх збирають цивільні.
Приміром, співробітники Halo Trust -
міжнародної неурядової організації - найбільшої у світі з розмінування.
Виклики, з якими вони стикнулися в Україні,
відрізняються від будь-якої іншої зони конфлікту.
Особливість нашої країни у тому, що в нас є гостра проблема розтяжок.
Власне, в жодній іншій державі ми не стикалися з цим.
Тому експерти, які заїжджали в Україну, були змушені вигадувати нові методи.
А це дуже непросто.
За кілька років після того, як військові встановили розтяжки,
поля заросли бур’янами,
тому побачити ці небезпечні "пастки" майже неможливо.
Взагалі не можна сказати, на скільки ти просунешся за день,
тому що різна рослинність - можна пройти 20 метрів,
можна 10 - абсолютно різну відстань. Головне тут - безпека.
Вдалечині тривають бої.
Нинішня лінія фронту лише у кількох кілометрах звідси.
Тим часом експерти шукають протитанкові міни.
А от протипіхотних мін, поширених у  Ємені та Мазамбіку, в Україні значно менше.
В цій міні більше семи кілограмів вибухової речовини,
і привести її в дію може лише важка техніка.
Bтім, під силу це і трактору.
І хоча зовсім недалеко гримить війна, життя триває, а люди і надалі обробляють землю.
Це усе, що лишил ося від трактора, на якому Василь Кисельов їхав у 2015-му.
Військові запевнили його, що на полі - безпечно.
Контузило. Прийшов до тями, бачу - горю
Намагався вибратися сам, але не зміг.
Зрештою, мене витягнули через заднє скло і загасили ноги.
А коли потрапив до лікарні, мені сказали, що піді мною були іще міни.
Тобто виходить ви постійно по цих мінах їздили…
І вивозили мене з поля по мінах.
Василь отримав дуже великі опіки ніг.
Після трьох років та кількох операцій він досі відчуває хронічний біль.
І досі неясно, чи зможе він колись знову працювати.
На полі знайшли гранату, яка не вибухнула.
Однак неурядові організації, такі як Halo Trust,
не мають права розпоряджатися подібними знахідками.
Вони повинні чекати військових, які зберуть боєприпаси, а це може тривати тижнями.
Скільки часу знадобиться на те, щоб знайти усі міни, залишені під час боїв, не може сказати ніхто.
Зрозуміло одне - вони ще довго становитимуть небезпеку для людей.